[Music]
hello and welcome
to
gamespot after dark episode
152 i think you might be look watching
him
listen if you're watching you're like
hold on a second
didn't they say they were doing these
live and in the studio again and you
know what we are we are doing them live
in the studio but sometimes we're forced
to do them from home
today is one such day
because we've had various
circumstances come up that has forced us
to return to our zoom
caves and do this episode
i am tawasein your host
joined by
john luke psyche
hello this is the uh the first time i'm
doing it live in my house i really hope
my computer doesn't explode
if it falls apart
it's john lew's computer please send 30
90s to help it come back to life
by
the pod father zaddy
there we go you got the name right that
that that's the new name the podzaddy is
what i'm going gonna call you for sure
that's fine
call me whatever you like tomorrow okay
great she's not jacob we got in trouble
for that just not jacob do not do not
call me we gotta we gotta we got a stern
talking to uh after last week's episode
yeah and we're also joined by jordan
remay
what up what up
how's everyone doing today i kind of
after going after going doing a bunch of
these in in the um office i'm kind of i
feel uncomfortable doing them and i like
it my office kind of weird but you know
we got we gotta stay safe we gotta be
cool i gotta look around and be like do
i have anything
my pants on is can you what can you guys
see
do you know what happened to me i like i
like started editing a piece at 12 and i
was like i'll go to the gym then i'll do
the podcast and then i got ready to go
to the gym i looked at my watch and it
was time to do the podcast and i was
like oh my god so i like fully lost
track of time if we were in the office
you would have been like time to go to
the podcast room
and i'll be like okay great but no today
time is time is once again slipping away
uh let's get into the what we've been
playing doing seeing eating you know
tasting experiencing section of the
podcast um we're going to start with
jordan what you've been up to i swear to
god if you say apex legends i will
[Laughter]
does he have the power to boot me out of
this discord call does he have the
authority i don't know we'll find i
guess we'll find out
i must say uh
you can talk about it go on apex legends
is working again so i am like completely
back on my daily [ __ ] of playing
apex legends practically every single
day um
and
it's
yeah it's it's apex it's still
good it's still doing its thing it's
still the best battle royale on the
market i don't care what mark says
fortnite is dumb um
uh
i i'm excited to just get back into it
and go back to my daily grind of playing
the game that's always been my like
usual go-to after work to just play a
couple of matches of apex just to
relax and uh whatnot i'm a bit
sad jealous apex legends mobile is going
into season two soon so they announced
their new character today and it's like
a sound based uh
dj musician character i've been wanting
a character like a musician character a
sound based d listen
listen what is wrong with developers
right now
[ __ ] hell
come on
grow up
is that not really cool that's not isn't
that really cool
does anyone remember lucio though i
don't think anyone remembers lucy
playing lucio yesterday you relax
yourself okay i would i would love
though if he like pulled out like his
like ds and and got like you know one of
those like sound programs on there and
like that's how he's making his music
like
it's like a little animation
to be fair to be fair overwatch has
copied apex now they technically copied
and then did it better but they have now
copied apex with jungkook do they copy
and paste
she's just mad maggie the character that
apex uh
got um
a few seasons back like
junker queen is just a better variation
like they're both uh
aussies although i think mad maggie is
kiwi specifically uh
and they both kind of have that whole
like uh
strong woman from the outlands vibe that
uses uh like put together machinery
yeah
developers man
i mean they all watched fury road and
we're just like yup we gotta put that in
there
why is everyone making the same
characters over and over because there's
only so many heroes in the world
creativity is dead tomorrow creativity
died with an interesting character right
now
do it then how do australians feel about
the fact that my mind palace trying to
think of something
dude from
uzbekistan okay uses
a pogo stick
and
is
has a pet parrot there you go
no that character does not exist in any
battle royales what what what would
their abilities be
okay they bounce on you it's a throwback
it's it's honoring the classic super
mario mechanism design of jumping on
people's head you can shoot a gun but if
you manage to pull out your pogo stick
and bounce off their head it does an
instant kill
just a character who can just naturally
bunny hop up like every pro
he's got a rocket-powered pogo stick
there you go
none of those exist in any of these
games it's just instead everyone's like
what if we created a dj
sound powers everyone in his response
like by god he's done it he's come up
with a totally unique original totally
unique character quick put it through
the diversity uh spreadsheet let's make
sure that it hits uh gets at least an
eight
before we prove it if i say we're gonna
make we're gonna make her an asian girl
with uh what is it when people have two
eyes of two different color uh like one
what's that called
heterochromia yeah something like that
sounds right yeah
uh yeah she's called rhapsody and she
looks pretty cool but like tam said she
kind of feels like
apex's attempts to be like you know we
haven't copied all of overwatch's roster
yet there are still a couple of
characters that we have yet to
emulate
for our battle royale so we'll put it in
the mobile game imagine imagine seeing
all these games copying each other and
then being some being a battleborn and
being like we copied everything and
cared about us
it just failed
they didn't copy anything they were just
unfortunate and a batman in the chat has
said lawyer hibachi chef nailed it
yes there's a new hero and then into the
cast our friends uh into the eighth just
put video game mouth feel which is
deeply unsettling to me
but yeah so apex is working
yes it is working again i can finally
uh
have a purpose to keep doing stuff after
work in apex what did you do that was
deeply concerning
[Laughter]
did you just like sit in a dark room
i i i played stuff like rocket league
and watched people play uh d and d and
watched anime for the most part like
without apex in my life and i just
slid into
it threw off the balance is what you're
saying
yeah i i need something active i need
the joy and sensation of proving that
i'm better than other people in this
world by being have you tried neon white
because you could
not do that
neon white is great for that
i
almost
played neon white and
then i got distracted by something else
my apex
[Music]
dj
well my steam deck came in and so i
wanted to play some like a
new
well not apex because i figured if i
played a shooter like apex on the steam
deck i was going to get stomped into the
ground like immediately
but as i was going to play neon white i
was like downloading everything i'm like
you know
there are no like volleyball games like
on xbox or playstation or switch but
maybe there are volleyball games on
steam and so i just like went on to see
him and i just typed in volleyball um
a lot of a lot of nasty folks on steam
because like the first like 12 responses
were like dating sims adults like strip
the clothes off the main ball players
like playing a volleyball game where you
could freeze time
and like check out your opponent in
midair while the time was frozen i'm
like what the [ __ ] there is a whole
generation of gamers that grew up on
dead or live extreme and you know what
they're just they are now at the point
where they can make the games they want
and
they're they're doing it
i love the idea of all that generation
of gamers not knowing that a that is not
knowing that volleyball exists in any
other fashion like they don't know that
volleyball is real all they know is that
it's just a perverted version of
that like that that is
women yeah yeah that is tied to the
volleyball experience you can't have one
without the other like yeah so like one
day one of these people is like out in
public and sees volleyball happening and
they're like
what the [ __ ]
is this it's a man are they laughing
what's going on
where's the insane anime titties yeah
that dude is wearing a shirt what's
going on
so yeah i spent a solid just
like 45 minutes to an hour just
scrolling down through
steam and under the volleyball tag just
trying to find like one
competent good volleyball game to did
you fight
i
maybe i found one that it's it's not out
yet but there's a demo and the demo is
on my steam deck and i only went through
the tutorial and i'm like okay the
tutorial was good i need to actually
like play the actual game in the
demo it's called a spike air
volleyball um
and it's it's kind of
structured
similarly to
um
switch sports volleyball but it's more
so on like a
2d plane so you're watching the uh court
from the side as you're controlling like
four people on one side of the court so
it's like okay the ball's coming to your
side you have to
press whether or not you're going to try
to pass the ball or die for the ball or
scoot back to like spin the ball uh up
high and then it's like all right in the
time that it takes the ball to reach
your setter you have like four different
inputs you can press to uh decide where
the ball is going and then once the ball
is set you have to then have all these
different inputs for
how your hitters can actually uh hit the
ball and then there's different inputs
for the block
no
a game that doesn't volleyball
he spent 40 minutes and found a porn
game and is like this
i found nothing like butt porn games and
then this one game that was like not a
poor game and actually somewhat good and
i looked at the developers and they have
like 200 followers on twitter and i'm
like oh so
like this is like uh
i think this is a bunch of people who
are like you know there's not actually
like a real volleyball game out there so
we're gonna try to do it and they're
losing to the pornographic
games
uh steam is in
bad form uh pretty much any tag you look
at it's gonna have some amount of views
if you are if you're a little pervert
like about about like scantily clad
characters and if you're horny if you're
a horny gamer steam is a
absolute gold mine of disgusting [ __ ]
usually that's what i'm discovering with
the steam deck that's that's what i've
been discovering
i don't i don't know like
i the only explanation i ever i have is
that gabe is into it because like if
otherwise i would most other places
would be like we got filter this year
it's disgusting and weird
but like gabe must be like
love it i got my knives and my weird my
weird uh
themed creepy games
sandals or whatever yeah
bless him he's a good lad that
um but yeah uh we've got a couple of
questions in the chat one from luis
schmart who says um what position do you
play in volleyball and how tall are you
uh i am five eleven which is
i guess somewhat tall for real life and
not very tall uh for volleyball um i've
played a few positions in volleyball
most often i play middle blocker which
i'm a little bit
too
short for usually you want someone who's
like 6'4 to play a middle blocker
but i can jump really high which is very
beneficial uh if i'm not playing middle
blocker then i'm usually
doing my best at trying to play
setter and doing my best to try to get
the ball to
where it needs to go usually not very
well because i don't play setter often
enough to be good at it
my most important question is were you
playing volleyball before you saw
haikyuu
i was playing volleyball before i played
uh saw iq i i started in middle school
kept playing in high school
got to college and was playing like club
uh volleyball at uh college at st mary's
and like a bunch of people were like
hey have you watched haikyu i think you
would like it and i wasn't like super
into anime at that point so i was like
that weeb [ __ ] nah i i don't care about
that oh that was your introduction so
then it was and then it wasn't until
like years later that i'm like
oh i remember like six years ago people
being like yo high q is pretty good and
i started watching like oh damn this is
like
really [ __ ] good
jordan what else have you been checking
out
uh i have also been checking out uh a
uh adventure game a monkey island uh
inspired game called a voodoo detective
um
which is uh it's pretty good i'm only
like
two ish hours into it uh so far just it
came out about a
month two months ago i want to say uh
and it's about uh this dude who
practices
voodoo um and is uh trying to be the
detective uh in this uh on this island
that's becoming more and more uh
gentrified as more like white people are
vacationing there and they're replacing
um a lot of the local spots with um
more uh
like uh
plays on things like trader joe's and
target and uh stuff like that and your
first case that you have is like this
woman comes in and she can't remember
who she is and so you have to use a
mixture of both like
uh traditional adventure game like
detective skills like find the right
item to do the right thing to figure out
the next step of the case well also at
the same time like you have this uh book
of
voodoo where it's like here's all these
like different uh like voodoo spells
that um
the devs did like some research to
figure out and so like to do some of the
spells you would have to find the
ingredients
uh to perform uh that spell and
sometimes you need to rely on voodoo to
figure out what you need to do next or
how to get the next step in the case
it's pretty good uh the writing is
awesome it's voice acted which is
surprising i feel like from such a small
studio and the voice acting
is pretty good i'm really enjoying it i
like uh point and click adventure games
uh
and voodoo detective kind of like hits
this spot of like
uh mystery as well as the same time like
kind of diving into this idea of like
island uh culture being like slowly uh
overrun by like tourists and like trying
to like deal with that while at the same
time like trying to solve this mystery
and um i'm like this this is cool this
is my [ __ ] i like story driven games
like yeah i'm looking at some
screenshots
uh i'm playing it on my steam deck and
uh on my uh pc i basically just go uh
back and forth like i'll usually start
playing it on my pc and like when i'm
tired of sitting in this chair i'll get
up and open the steam deck and play it
for like
45 minutes like on that on the couch uh
interesting yeah this looks cool i'm
gonna check it out that's the one thing
that i want to get more into like
playing like point-and-click adventure
style games on my steam deck because it
works really well right so
um
um i played this girl losing a final car
actually is it called final cut
direction it is final cut one
um
first before i jump back into any of
these john peter you need anything new
but anything else jordan that you've
been playing watching checking out
eating you know
well i i eat food
i'm still here i i eat food every every
day i eat at a much healthier cadence
now that i'm not going into the office
all the time and just forgetting to get
up to go eat lunch and then like tay and
rob are just shaking their heads at me
at like
3 45. you're like 4pm rolls by and
you're like i'm off for lunch i'm like
you go home in a hot an hour
you know sometimes the words are just
flowing and you just completely forget
to that your body needs nourishment in
order to survive it happens sometimes
five times a week it do be happening if
i could not eat ever that would be ideal
yeah it's just a waste you know like i
just want to eat when it tastes
fun you know but yeah specifically with
lunch like oh
if i could get rid of lunch that's a
thing i needed you like the idea of
because when you said i wish i could not
eat i i thought you meant eliminate food
like as a as a thing but if what you're
saying is if you could sustain yourself
without having to eat but then eat for
fun your leisure you know with friends
you know go out and eat with people yeah
that's a good way to approach it i would
love that too that would be cool
um jean-luc what are you up to
i admittedly haven't been playing much
new games i did beat neon white gamer oh
okay maybe
that game's real good um i will probably
i hundred percent of it uh although
that's not counting the stuff you unlock
after you beat it so there's like a
bunch of like hard challenge run modes
which seem
very difficult and i probably will not
do those or at least not right now
but i don't really have much else to say
about that game that we've already said
uh i did watch it's good yeah it's real
good should play it um it's it's really
fun to beat everyone's times
um well
my times
oh okay did you go back in and do i have
to go back now
well so i i started on switch like i
talked about last time but i ended up
getting it on pc and i have been moving
at a snail's pace because i don't move
on to the next level until i'm top of
the leaderboard unless someone has an
absurd time so right now i think i'm
like the third or fourth uh mission in
and i'm at the top of the leaderboard on
almost everyone which means i'm beating
dan reichert which is important to me
and mary
and it was good when he finished a run
and see his name below mine every time
you know i don't know i don't know if he
acknowledged it but i mean his times
were i i was watching here watching it
as well and i was looking at his time
and i was like this man talk mad [ __ ]
for your house he does he's playing
every single time he's like
[ __ ] i could smoke this dude easily
that was my motivation because on on
fire escape mary and dan were bragging
about their times and i was like all
right see how this is to be fair they
finished the game they're far ahead of
me but like so far
ain't no thing are they wait because
i've been doing the same thing where i'm
like i fixate on one level at a time and
like the the person to be that is not
being given the respect that he deserves
is andy cortez uh
kind of well i'm not friends with him so
i can't see what that dude is a beast at
that game
um but yeah
does he get like the hidden red uh
i think so metals and stuff too sure
i've gotten a good number of those too a
few of those as well
and watch the neon white uh
open
um on giantbomb.com because this is a
lot of fun it involves it's um
on the giant bomb side is jeff and dan
and then nexlanders brad and vinnie are
there alex boniello's there and then um
jess freudberger is doing commentary and
it's it was hilarious it's like
sidesplayingly funny at times
um there's there's technical issues
there's
dan doing a baby's voice for some reason
there's there's a lot of ups and downs
but it's worth checking out but yeah
neon white is great
carry on john look oh uh i finally
watched dr strange uh the multiverse of
madness yesterday
i did too i got real high and uh
and watched it which is probably the
best way to watch it to be honest um
i enjoyed it that was good i i had a fun
time with it it's uh
it's kind of all over the place like
there's a lot that happens in it and
it's um
i don't know like how cohesive that make
necessarily is as a movie but like it's
nice
but but i think i ended up
and maybe because i was really high but
i just really enjoyed uh
like its individual moments and i
enjoyed the individual character stuff
like with i i didn't
uh get spoiled on like where that movie
goes so i i quite liked the villain and
like their arc and and like those
emotional beats i really liked and i
just thought i had a lot of really fun
set pieces um
it's like
you kind of have to say like for a
marvel movie i do i feel like still
because it's like oh i wish it went like
when it went weird it was cool but i'm
also like oh i wish it went weirder in
in spots you know or it's like ah
there's that sam raimi like energy but
you're like uh but he could still feel
like he's being constrained by it being
like a marvel film
um but it's like i thought all the fight
scenes were probably the most like
creative interesting
fight scenes out of any marvel movie
i've seen recently like i like they had
a bunch of interesting set pieces where
they're like being chased or it's like
oh okay it isn't just like
i'm gonna shoot my super power laser at
you and i'm gonna shoot my super power
laser like i feel like they had
interesting setups of like oh
this person's doing this how are they
gonna counter it and
i'm sorry i'm being like really vague i
still want to like spoil it i guess for
people who haven't seen it but uh i
don't know i did i had a good time with
it and i i thought it was just kind of
like weird and uh it was also really
violent for a marvel movie which was
kind of fun like uh oh yeah the picking
part that i thought
there's a couple parts where it got
really violent and i was like
damn okay but it's only for like five
minutes not even five minutes just like
for like three minutes it's like
ridiculously violent yeah that through
those three minutes are pretty dang good
um i thought and and yeah yeah yeah i
don't know it's got it's got that weird
sam raiminess uh
i really enjoyed the uh the bruce
campbell cameo was a lot of fun
yeah it was that account cameo was fun
until it for me really overstayed his
welcome
in the in the credit sequence where i
was like oh you're doing this again i
see oh
sure sure that's fair although i imagine
you probably it probably is like less
fun because you had to like sit there
and wait for it in the theater i am
guessing where like i'm on disney plus
and i can just like skip right to it and
then just do it and just watch it and be
like okay that's fine i gotta be like
what all right i had to sit here for
like 10 [ __ ] minutes for that i guess
yeah
i didn't even i didn't even make it to
the post-credits scene i finished the
movie but i just blanked and turned it
off that's fine you didn't miss anything
it's totally fun
because someone else mentioned he shows
up again and i was like huh i don't
remember that i must have missed it but
that's why i missed it because i didn't
see the post-credits scene it's fine you
didn't miss much yeah i'm trust me i'm
not concerned missing marvel movies
totally fine
uh is are you going to go and see thor
i'll probably wait again like with this
one it was like i just didn't feel
compelled enough to see doctor strange
in theaters and i saw it at home and
felt totally fine about it and i kind of
feel the same about
thor especially kind of hearing that it
also is sort of like a weird incohesive
movie
like the reviews i was reading for thor
sounded like kind of the same problems
that doctor strange had where it's like
neat ideas and neat set pieces but like
it's kind of all over the place and i'm
like huh
uh this current phase of use
uh this current phase of marvel uh that
was uh i think mason on twitter talking
about it specifically um
but uh i think yeah this this phase of
marvel is
pretty like
i don't know it's it's it's weird it's
like all over i'm not like a huge marvel
person like but i like i've seen most of
them and enjoy them for the most part
but like
there is
that normal like oh everything feels
cohesive and all connects and like this
movie goes to this movie there is none
of that in the recent marvel movies at
all it's very strange
it does feel a bit off the rails
currently yeah which is
kind of weird but
it is
i'm excited for thor that was the one
that i was like hell yeah um after
ragnarok because ragnarok is one of my
favorites
um
but yeah i'm gonna see that hopefully
this week we'll see
but yeah anything else
uh
no
watched a bunch of anime
oh i uh
jordan will
uh for jordan finished watching um
kagia sama the final season i think the
final season yeah is it because it had a
very definitive the end we talked about
this on the podcast this is the final
season when um when michael was on
because we were like
telling him he should watch it it's uh
probably the best like
high school romance anime
like if like if i were to tell because
it's like as a genre right it's like oh
you have like your slice of life high
school romance anime and there's a ton
of them and a lot of them are very
like just whatever right super fine
a lot of the same jokes a lot of the
same kind of like repeating elements if
i were to tell someone like oh you
should watch like
one just one that is like the peak of
that
genre it would be cocky it is absolutely
hilarious it goes completely off the
rails um
in some bits the
but it also like
stays very true to the characters and i
think um
like when it gets serious about like
it's relationship stuff it gets really
serious uh and it just like strikes that
perfect balance of uh
like comedy and then like kind of like
teen drama um
it's really good it's and
there's your favorite bit what's your
favorite bit from the show because i
think my favorite bit is probably the
president needing to turn uh
to ask for help uh on oh
things uh from chica and her just like
being like this is my son that i
need to
it's it's her being like this is my son
and then it turning into like i hate my
son and you have like ruined me as a
person and at the end we're like
her sister's trying to like be like oh
president seems pretty cool and she's
like do not
do not this this man is is just up don't
don't you he will ruin you
um
i
yeah that [ __ ] it's really good
i'm glad it looks like uh from what i
can tell jake looks like he's adding
kage osama to his watch list
yes yeah i'm sure i'm sure he's super
into it
yeah yeah yeah i mean the fun way to
like
the the way i pitched it to michael
which is like a good way to pitch it um
is that it's basically like
death note but like uh for like a
romance um because the whole point is
that the it's basically like this battle
of wills between the two characters
where they're trying
they they are in love with each other
but they refuse they're too proud to
admit it so they're trying to get the
other person to admit it so you'll have
these like
l versus lifestyle like mind battles
where they are trying to like put the
other in a trap to like get them to like
admit that they love them and it's like
that's the conceit of like each bit so
it's always like every every bit is like
a battle between the two of them and
it's very good you think you'd get
tiresome after a while but it actually
like it's
regularly funny it's regularly funny
they get really weird with some of the
jokes there's like
there's a lot of video game jokes which
is really fun like like there's like a
dark souls reference uh yeah they did a
really fun persona joke um like they
they get really weird with some of the
humor and it's it's just so funny yeah i
have many episodes and where can maybe
watch you can find it on crunchyroll
there's three seasons and i think each
season was like
12 episodes and then i the first and
then the final season i think was like
13 episodes so it's like
around like 35 to 40 episodes or
something like total um it's pretty
reasonable to watch honestly
um drink easy yeah easy
wait until you hear what i've been
playing though
what have you been playing jake
i've been playing xenoblade chronicles
3. wow which is uh
anime
yeah blade chronicles i mean you know
jrpgs animes they're different things
the way i see it
different different things yeah they're
different things jordan i don't know
different things
they're they're different
i don't know man i i just spent a whole
i spent a whole
absolutely not
i don't know man i i just spent a whole
five minutes talking about like kagia
and how that's pretty good and i sit and
look at xenoblade i'm like this shit's
too weeby for me i can't play this
tell us about uh xenoblade chronicles uh
jake as much as you can because you're
yeah for preview right so i played it
for preview i can't talk about a whole
lot i think if you're really curious
about xenoblade after this i'd recommend
checking out the preview there's both a
video and written thing if you want
more details i would say but just as an
overview so far i think it's very good i
think the combat is
is excellent i mean they they
seem to have gotten rid of some of the
gotcha elements from two which for me
personally bugged me quite a bit
um and i think that'll probably make
fans happy
uh
but the the the combat is is for me
personally why i come to these games
they're usually very good
uh mr blum d asked if i played one and
or two i reviewed one um the definitive
edition and then i covered two but i
didn't finish two
um
but yeah i mean i think like xenoblade
fans are gonna be really happy based on
what i've played so far uh the story is
a little nonsense um it it has an
interesting setup but there's a lot of
weird
jrpg isms in there and piecing that
together
isn't necessarily hard it's just
it
takes a lot of energy i would say
um especially if you're not
xenoblade 2 was like super
[ __ ] horny and weird
no it's not as horny and weird so
the the development for two apparently
was very strange because a lot of that
team was working on breath of the wild
uh i guess they only had like one
programmer for that entire game for most
of it which is absolutely absurd wow uh
and they had a lot of like
other artists create characters and i
guess a hentai artist actually made some
of the characters that's why i'd
[Music]
we got a whole team working on breath of
the wild i guess we should contract some
people out and then like the guy's like
i know the perfect person let me get
them in here
when i found that out i was like oh that
makes a lot of sense
um
in that sense this one is scaled back a
lot uh which is which is
nice it's
personally i think it makes the game
more enjoyable
speak for yourself a lot of people yeah
i know a lot of people would disagree
and i'm sure there are going to be
people who will be mad about the lack of
or
the
excessive amount of clothing in this
game but
anyway like i said i i haven't played a
whole lot uh but
what i've played is is quite good and i
think fans are going to be excited for
it
i think if you're not into xenoblade i
don't know if this game's gonna sell you
on it
uh
i i think i think if you're thinking
about xenoblade you have to ask yourself
two questions the first is do i like mmo
combat if the answer is yes you will
probably like this game the combat is a
little more
not fleshed out but a little more active
than mmo combat i would say um so it's
not just auto attack auto attack auto
attack it's managing meters using
different arts uh chaining those arts
together with different characters and
so on very similar to the other games
but if you're not familiar that's
definitely something worth considering
and the other question is if you think
you can buy into this sort of wacky jrpg
story because if you can't
it would probably be a tough sell too
because
the story is
what i've played it it can be tough to
follow i would say
um that said
uh i'm i'm very curious to see where it
goes because i won't get into spoilers
for one or two but they did some really
interesting things with how those games
wrapped up
uh and i imagine that's going to play a
big role in three so i'm excited to see
where that goes and i then i imagine
fans are too
um
yeah i would check out the preview for
more specifics because i don't wanna
i can only say so much
okay
check out the preview and the video on
gamespot or
youtube.com for more on that what else
you've been checking out
just neon white and i think i already uh
shared my piece about that how i
switched to pc and now i'm just chasing
scores i don't think i'll i think by the
time i finish that game i'll have like
50 hours logged in it because i'm moving
so slow just
getting the top of leaderboard on
everything
it's fun though it's so much fun yeah i
haven't been playing much if i'm honest
like i've just been kind of
playing the same stuff again which is
overwatch
because that beta is ongoing so i've
been playing a bunch of that it's a lot
of fun
i'm playing a bunch on pc with a few
others and uh lucy and andy cortez and
and a few other folks as well and it was
a good time um beyond that i played a
little bit of dnf duel
which is uh the latest arc system works
fighting game based on a
an old or not an old but like well i
guess so it's like 10 years old now an
rpg um from oh i can't remember the
company's name
crap i forgot it um but it's like
dungeon fighter online or something like
that um but i didn't play that original
um
rpg um uh
nexon is is the uh pokes behind dungeon
fighter online but the fighting game is
good it's it's really interesting
because like i was talking about this
with jason um giant bomb but like
um
arxis has like got into a place where
they make really good they make a lot of
fighting games they make a lot of really
good fighting games but almost every one
of those barring like dragon ball
fighters and guilty gear feels just
entirely disposable
like they don't put out fighting games
to last they put them out just to almost
like
fill a contract if you know what i mean
yeah um
yeah they did that with um grand blue
fantasy they did it with dnf and well
even even like other stuff it just feels
like
there's no there's no longevity to them
if you know what i mean like yeah
showing up at like evil they're not at
like major tournament plays they're like
just kind of
someone asked us to make a fighting game
out of their license and we did it and
we did a good one but we're moving on to
something else now i mean yeah that's
kind of like
even persona 4 arena was sort of that
but like i guess just happened to catch
on more than those other ones oh hey uh
my discord popping up filling up the
screen
um yeah sorry you guys didn't see that
but the uh twitch chat definitely did uh
um but no but um
but yeah like that game weirdly blew up
and probably because it was persona was
a bigger deal um and it's like
i mean i actually like grand blue like
it was a gremly versus a good fighting
game but you're right in that it's like
it
it does feel like it's kind of just
filling this like
contract quota versus like you could
tell like they're doing this so that
they can keep you know afloat and make
money so that they can go make another
guilty gear or make you know like
something they're or not make more blaze
blue right like you know they can yeah
that's the thing like i don't know what
the end game is or like what the
like if they're doing this work stuff
for anyone and everyone what is the game
that they're or the
or the project that they're really like
focused on making a big deal like their
their passion project guilty gear right
it would be it'd be guilty kind of it'd
be guilty yeah but like
i guess my thinking is like what
distinguishes guilty gear from these
other fighting games they look feel very
similar you know you know i mean like it
feels like
i mean you get the only thing that
really distinguishes guilty gear is it
it like um dnf and and granblue is is
also a very good game um but it's got a
lot of similar similarities um and the
only thing that really distinguishes it
is it's got
heritage it's got like a history to it
and that's why it exists in like
you know esports or like competitive
fighting game scenes it's the one that
has more um kind of traction of their
all their games outside of dragon ball
fighters guilty gear is also kind of
where they push their tech more i would
say from like an artistic standpoint
like you know exert was the one where
they like introduced the whole like cell
shaded kind of 3d look that was like
mind-blowing at the time you're like
holy crap this looks amazing and then um
you know then they did it with dragon
ball and then they did it with grand
blue and then they had strive which uh
isn't quite the leap because it's just
more iterative but it is like
you know a lot better they do a lot more
with shading and
and stuff so i think it's just kind of
like
that's probably where their passion lies
is in in pushing that stuff and then um
i mean obviously i'm not a professional
guilty gear player but i know that a lot
of people really really love guilty gear
and kind of like the way that game
operates and uh it's specific kind of
like you know
intricacies that versus like something
like say uh grand blue and then like
persona um and i assume dnf is probably
somewhat similar those try and be more
like um approachable
yeah
the dnf is definitely way more
approachable it's got like directional
inputs basically like presser direction
and
special button and you get like
something cool going on it's yeah you
just jump in and hit buttons i for me
like i i started playing it i enjoyed it
i was like there's clearly depth here
there's a lot yeah it's really well made
it's got interesting characters in there
but there's just something about it that
i know that i won't stick with and it's
just like it feels very like i said
disposable i'm like i'm not going to
play this two weeks from now
is dnf duel based on anything because
like grand blue
is at least like makes sense for me like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's based on the nexon uh
mmo
rpg dungeon fighter online
um which like i said it was like it's
like 10 years old at this point yeah um
so it's people people clearly it's funny
because like it's based on something
that's a 10 year old property that
clearly is is popular but they do
nothing with it like it it's got a
it's got a ps4 story mode it barely has
a story and and like it's just like this
is bizarre you like grand blue they made
a story mode it wasn't great it was okay
but like at least they made something
out of it this is just like they just
like stuffed you know like all right
let's just get this thing done
i mean i guess this is a shape
yeah i guess on this regard like i kind
of prefer
like
you know oh hey we have this anime
property or we have this you know thing
and we want to do like a game for it i
rather like you give it to arc systems
and they'll make at least like a good
fighting game if if not somewhat
disposable versus like
just the like glutton of arena fighters
that like you know
bandai bandai makes and stuff so it's
like i prefer that but
yeah it's definitely them trying to fill
this like quota
and also like
granblue is a weird one and i assume dnf
does the same thing where it's like
it that's meant for a different market
it's not meant for us it's like we got
it and that's cool and there are people
here who also like grand blue but it's
like rambly's not like
like
you know that's in like china and like
you know um like the asian market is
where like grand blue is like
big and that's probably who they're
actually trying to court with those
kinds of games
people in china and jake because he
loves anime um yeah it's it's i i played
it it's fun it's approachable it's got
it's clearly like got a good amount of
like um production value in it
but i won't
i won't i won't play again probably
outside of this week like at this point
i'm like more interested in like
i i want something with longevity i want
something that i know that if i'm gonna
spend some time playing this i i will
play it for a while and other people
will be around to play i don't trust
that this is gonna be around
four months from now in any meaningful
way six months from now like grand blue
kind of fell off pretty quickly
compared to
most the lifestyle of most fighting
games like even
even the the fighting games that don't
have a lot of like positive buzz around
them stick around for longer and i'm
more inclined to play them like three
five five for example had a rough start
but it's it trucked on and people stuck
with it and that's partly because of
street fighter but also because you know
there's something more about it
yeah or like um
caffeine brandon in the chat just
mentioned skull girls like that game
still around and like good on that team
they've had a lot of ups and downs with
that uh
like the
studio got dissolved multiple times or
something like that um but
they're still around and they're still
putting out new characters and good for
them
yeah so that's the main thing that i've
been playing it's fine um outside of
that i've been like
kind of chipping away at neon white
having having some fun with that i
installed um tales of veriz and started
playing that um
it's a good game too
wow
didn't expect that from you jake
i love the tales games they're often
that's that's a fun game it's also
insane like
i love anime i am the anime but like
sometimes anime games do things that i'm
like get a grip
for god's sake and like and most of the
time these days it's when one person
says the name of another character and
it's just the most like cringe-worthy
name that you can think of where it's
like
god power
damien the third exavious and i'm like
get [ __ ] who's
who came up with that name
it's just so like it's in the first cut
scene where you meet like the first boss
character his name's balsef
first of all
and and he's like talking to some other
dude and he says his name and i'm just
like oh for [ __ ] sake
are you are you streaming it or are you
just playing i started streaming a while
back but i i stopped streaming um but
yeah i'm just playing it on the side
um it's got a good combat
uh model which i like quite a bit it's
very freeform
um interesting style for the premise if
there's more characters with names like
that and they talk a lot i might just be
like
i might might be time to stop with this
now i've got limited like [ __ ] uh
what'd you call it uh ability to stand
annoying stuff like that these days
where i'm just like i'm just this is
deeply embarrassing to me i just don't
want to be a part of it i i didn't make
it through a rise i really enjoyed it
but i got to a point where i was
probably how you feel i was like i can't
do this anymore and then just stop and
nope out of it and haven't touched it
since
yes i just i just want to find the
i'm just looking
lord gonna belt valkyries
like what that'd be real
that's an actual character's name
and there's another character called daw
and i'm just like jack why
uh for once just call him dave or
something man
let's relax live
yeah just get don't go don't go as bad
as there needs to be
[Laughter]
clive is the name of everyone's high
school principal like don't don't do
this
um but yeah i played a bit of that on
this one um but that's about it
uh i'd i've been like watching
um a few things here and there that are
kind of fun uh
i'm still watching a bunch of uh i
forgot the name of the anime as well the
the one with the little kid on netflix
um oh
god birthdays
alone yes yeah i've been watching like
one or two episodes at a time it's just
so good it's so fun it's so cute
everyone should everyone should watch it
kotara lives alone because it's like you
know this is cute and then at the end of
the episode it tells you something about
kotara and you're like
that was devastating why did they do
this
it's just like it's it's like you
because he's a little but he's a little
kid he lives on his own
and he's like forced to do adult [ __ ]
like
grocery shopping and like uh stuff like
that at the same time as like going to
school and stuff like that
and then they're like oh you're like oh
he's so cute he's like doing adult stuff
on his own and then it's like he's doing
adult stuff because his life was tragic
and this is what happened that led him
to do this stuff and you're like
[ __ ] man i was just
um
but yeah that's that's that's all i've
been doing
uh in the chat mello run says clive just
challenged the party to a game of
pinochle
which is
just an amusing phrase to me let's move
on
what is p knuckle i've heard of that
before i love that i love the name but i
have no idea what it sounds it sounds
wildly american
it sounds
don't you dare but i wouldn't be
surprised if it ends up being asked by
just like as far as i've never been
challenged to a game of peanut corn the
streets of london
um whereas i feel like if i went to some
part of america they'll be like
y'all want to play some pinocchio
apparently it's a card game
it is united states that's us yep that
one's that one's honest there you go i
was right i was right
um let's move on to the topic of the
week which is gonna get spicy it's gonna
get spicy i didn't come up with this one
this is one from the podzotti himself
and the the topic of the week is
games that you can't stand
that everyone else seems to love
this is an interesting one
um since since the pod zaddy came up
with this one i'm gonna ask you to begin
with your submission now i gotta i gotta
ruin people's days first all right
uh i the game that i've tried to play so
many times
that i've never understood that i just
don't enjoy
is
assassin's creed ii
oh
i
played one
from start to finish which i thought was
okay you know i thought it did some cool
things at the time i was excited for two
and played it and was just not feeling
it i don't know why at the time i didn't
know why i was like huh everyone says
this is like one of the best games ever
at the time and i just couldn't get into
it
so i played three and three i didn't
like but i at least finished it
three's not good
three is not good no
okay no three three has its merits we
need to come back around people are like
three is great all right but like three
main is like are you all right that's
three threes
three is pretty good
it's not great but it's good i feel like
when you're when you're when your voice
is like reaching out
i don't think if you're like three is
good i believe you but if you're like
how do you say mass effect andromeda is
good we don't have to talk about this
we don't have to we don't have to talk
about how pretty good it is it's pretty
good that's pretty good um
but yeah i think like just the combat
never really clicked in any of the games
for me i didn't care much for the combat
i didn't care for like the whole a
circle of people standing around you you
fight one at a time
uh i also thought the opening to two was
incredibly slow and that was a reason
why i never got through it and then i'd
see things later about like fist fights
with the pope and i was like yeah maybe
maybe this game is not
the height of the franchise that is
yeah that's literally the final boss
of that game
i guess i guess now looking back i'm
like that's pretty dope you know but
like at the time i was like oh this game
is what that's how they end it this like
this cool assassin game but yeah you
know i i i i and
i say two but like honestly the entire
assassin's creed franchise has just
never clicked with me like i've
i i think the one thing i've always
really appreciated about the games is
the setting and like i will play
all of them at least a little just so i
can explore that setting but man
just
i i just find like the story and the
whole like
story intertwined like the whole
current day and story just so
uninteresting and dull and like even the
newer trilogy like while i had fun it
was just like
so much of that stuff i just felt like
was cripped from other games because
people were tired of what they were
doing before
um
so yeah i mean
pretty hard i think assassin's creed
generally the thing about that game and
i can understand it is because
like um
did you play at launch
two or
two yeah yeah i played i played at
launch i got that day one cause okay
i heard it was gonna be the best game
ever
so i think i think for me like it's hard
to enjoy that game now or like post
release in a if there's any sort of
meaningful time between at launch and
and you playing it because it was a game
where i think a lot of people
realized what a gameplay loop is
if you know what i mean like i think for
a lot of people they didn't pay
attention to that this was the game that
like
most obviously had a loop to it where
you did this went out did that came back
to the villa did this did that and it
was like that circular thing
um and i think that's also a game that
kind of also popularized gamifying that
loop in a more obvious way if you know
what i mean um and then obviously games
went on to just be that everywhere
especially ubisoft games right like
every game is now a loop and it was all
of ubisoft's games are assassin's creed
ii they've been making assassin creed 2
since assassin's creed 2 came out and
they just put it in on different skins
um but like even other places like other
games did that so i feel like the the
magic of it was like
becoming aware of the loop in a way and
then just being like giving yourself to
that whereas it now nowadays you're just
like yeah this is just a bog standard
video game i don't get it um yeah i i
think for me too a lot of it was i feel
like when assassin's creed 2 came out
that was very clearly you could tell
ubisoft was going to start moving in a
different direction you kind of talked
about that with um
how
they they they found that loop that
worked and they did it to death but like
i i i played i used to love ubisoft
games like those were usually my
favorite games back in the day like i
loved the rainbow six games i loved the
even the ghost recon games i thought
were great and of course the splinter
cell games are some of my favorite so
like i had this mindset where like if
it's a ubisoft game i'm probably going
to like it mind you do not feel that way
today but at the time
and i mean skull and bones wow i can't
even get the name right yeah
i'm curious
but but like i
i i remember when assassin's creed came
out and i was really excited for it
because it was a ubisoft game and i
thought the game was interesting and i
saw it through but i think when two came
out i played it and i was just like okay
they're not
they're moving in a different direction
than i would have would like these
ubisoft games there is an alternate
reality where to like leaned on like
different elements from one and would
have been like looking back on it a more
interesting game like i feel like that
like if they had leaned more into like
the
simulation like social like almost like
hitman-esque elements of like assassin's
creed one i think like looking back now
i would have been
i would they did it with far cry right
like far cry 2 was very simulation
focused and very
like very systems heavy uh and then
three kind of ditched that more for just
and then three sold up
million copies and then they copied that
which which is a shame popular loop
i look interesting aspects of one
carried on in the multiplayer of two
multiplayer brotherhood brotherhood
this week
yeah the best [ __ ] that assassin's creed
has done gameplay-wise has been in the
multiplayer like that stuff was so cool
and they just didn't really run with it
what i mean they did for what was it
brotherhood
yeah they did because it was brotherhood
was the first one that had it and they
brought it back for revelations and then
three four four was the last one
i think and then they did the whole like
uh co-op uh
raid type thing for
unity which was not nearly as popular or
as good
uh
but yeah see that's kind of like my out
of interest then jake are you
do you have any excitement or interest
for that rumored smaller assassin's
creed game that's coming out or in
development that is like a self-focused
experience
i i think i i would personally be more
excited for that not so much
because it's an assassin's creed game
but because it's an assassin's creed
game i might actually be able to finish
because i i think when you talk about
the newer trilogy of assassin's creed
games that's almost different beast like
i've played all those games
games yeah i i've played them for a for
like some i played for over 50 hours and
i didn't finish one of those
rookie numbers jake i know like valhalla
like that game was cool for like 10
hours find out you can play for 200 and
i was like [ __ ] no
it was one of the hardest reviews i
think i've ever had
and like
i i get why people do enjoy those games
because it's just like it's nice to have
a game to return to like night after
night and kind of just chip away at you
know like i i've
like people play destiny for that people
play other games i just
assassin's creed has changed so much
over the years and like i said i haven't
been a fan of the series at all so i
probably shouldn't be talking but like
the idea of a much shorter version of
one of those games
has me interested just
on the basis that i will
probably be able to finish that game and
i will probably like hopefully finish it
at the point where i'm still enjoying it
yeah for me like i think the most
exciting part of it is the fact that
they're like we're going to do some of
that stealth stuff that we we did back
in the day i'm like oh thank god um yeah
i i've played i played valhalla
literally for a minute one minute i
turned it on and i was like 60 seconds
it might have been less because i i
turned it on i was like installed it i
find it up and then i i think i talked
to you about something and you're like
yeah i'm like uh
500 hours in and i've done like i put a
lot of i put a lot of games
and i've done three percent of the game
i was like
no
i didn't know i used to love that
franchise as well like i
two i obsessed over brotherhood and like
revelations i played i think that was my
era like after so i played through three
i was like okay
he's losing me and then four black flag
um i was like okay this new era i'm just
it's it's too much fluff man it's too
much fluff for me like i need the focus
you didn't like black flag
not really i thought black foreign i
think i'm i prefer the the
the older arrow from two to like i guess
um
revelation revelations even the london
one
uh
that was after black flag
yeah so syndicate is where they reigned
in a bit more right like was less open
well it just had the unfortunate fact
that it came out after unity and people
were so burned on unity that no one
bought syndicate so ubisoft was like we
just need to change this franchise
completely and that's how we get it
is actually underrated um i would say
just and i think it's my favorite in the
entire series it's it's like a lot of
fun and it's got that humor it's got
like it's got some humor um
it's like plays with fantasy a bit more
more and like his fantasy and history a
bit more um in the way that um
the original ones did you know the whole
ezio invented the the espresso or the
cappuccino [ __ ] that that were you
considering
sugar yeah that kind of [ __ ] where it's
like you accidentally stumble into like
you know as like evie or whatever isn't
it what is her brother's name jacob
he stumbled into like jack the ripper
[ __ ] and like that kind of stuff where
it like intersects with real history
yeah fun
but then like it did get like it was
unfortunate because it came off it was
the next game after uni which everyone
hated and even like rogue was okay
but i feel like those two games just got
down a bit dirty because the reputation
and then they pivoted into let's make it
so no one can ever complete these games
was weird too because that was a period
where ubisoft was like ah well you know
what we've got two consoles or two
console generations that we're launching
on we don't want to put the same game on
both generations and we don't want to
abandon one so we're just going to make
two separate games that sounds way more
expensive but they did it they did it
they at least titled them differently
that generation because i remember the
generation before they released two
versions of splinter cell double agent
did not did not uh uh market the fact
that these games are very different
they're just double agent played on
whatever you want and years later i was
like holy [ __ ] there's a splinter cell
game i've never [ __ ] played
it was okay but still you know like
ubisoft baffles me some some of the
decisions they've made over the years
have been just so strange
is this gonna
sell co-op still playable
uh
kind of blacklist one yeah or are you
talking chaos theory no blacklist
blacklist is
yeah unless they try we should play some
blacklists that would be fun that'd be
fun if that game is aged as well as you
think uh but you you can do the gameplay
is kind of what you can you can get og
spy versus mercs working but you have to
it you have to spend like a whole
weekend
like installing a bunch of [ __ ] and you
know like take an s.a.t course like it's
it's a whole thing yeah it's a whole
process i'm good but blacklist works and
blacklist co-op is kind of fun because
yeah i remember playing yeah it was
quite fun maybe we should do that
on stream screen
luke what is a game
that you
can't stand but everyone seems to love i
feel like i'm i i
i never feel that strongly about like to
sort of go as hard as i can't stand but
something i've never gotten into or like
i keep trying to get into it and i just
don't
like it is um
like mmo combat
like i don't just the entire genre yeah
i won them two than three of them no i
actually turns out i don't i really
don't like it and
and i
i've been trying to like
wrestle with it more
uh as i'm trying to get through like uh
final fantasy 14. and i respect that
there's like a lot of elements to it
that i probably just like don't get of
like okay like the way classes work and
things like you know like tanking and
and
kind of like healers and i'm not saying
that there's no depth to it it's just
that like i've never
had a good grasp on it
because i i don't think any mmo has ever
done a good job explaining the actual
depth of that combat like every mmo is
just like hey you have a skill and
you're like okay i hit one to do that
and they're like cool
okay you've unlocked another skill this
one you hit two and you're like okay i
guess i'll hit two now and you never
under the game doesn't bother explaining
like well no you wanna like
set this up into setting this up and
things like chaining like it's
never
ever explained in any mmo i've tried so
i never understand it and so i'm just
sitting there being like
i i guess i'll hit four now because
that's the new skill i unlocked and it's
just it's so dull and
i i don't like it i've
i don't know
someone someone teach me someone tell me
how the [ __ ] this is actually supposed
to work
i feel like it is what you're right like
it's just not explained very well and
also like i think the thing that mmos do
is they
they ex the ones that do explain it
explain the basic function of it like
press one press two press three and
you're good and then all the actual
depth is like 30 hours into the game
once you've gone halfway through three
skill trees at which point it doesn't
come back to you and it's like hey what
you need to do now is take one two three
split them so you have six seven eight
in between them and like you have create
these rotations where you press this
this and this right and that will allow
you to do this this and this they just
don't do that they just leave you and
they're like get out of here you know to
press these buttons and you're like i've
been using a keyboard all my life you
didn't need to show me how to do that
yeah or or
like you know when you look at wow and
it's like okay you get to like the later
raid dungeon stuff and it's like
you watch these videos where people are
like i have like 20 macro keys set up
and i have to have like all these
different plugins to manage and the ui
just looks like a [ __ ] disaster and
you're like that looks the most unfun
thing like i don't i don't want to do
that i'm sure it's like a really cool
experience like i get it as someone who
plays like destiny raids i understand
like the raid experience and how fun
that can be but i look at like the
mechanics that you have to do to play
that and i go i don't want to do that
absolutely not um in the chat pinecino
says in final fantasy 14 there's a glow
around the next key to hit for a combo
yes i don't know that they're kind of
yes
i i have noticed that i have played many
hours of that game
i had no idea i think
because i was probably on the same boat
as you like i played the xenoblade games
which have that sort of mmo combat but
like for final fantasy 14 for example
like
what really helped it click for me was
just having someone there to explain
things as we go
like that made it a lot more
entertaining combat included but i know
you're talking about because i blindly
chose a tank and like for a while there
every
you know dungeonite going to people like
stan stance dance dance dance and i'm
like what the [ __ ] does stance mean like
is that for me after someone else what
stance
and you know come to find out that if
you're a tank you need to set your aggro
stance on so enemies will come at you
but but i
i get what you i totally get what you're
saying though because like i felt this
way for a long time and i think
i think
final fantasy 14 might be the one that
kind of changed my mind around it it's
still hard to say because i'm not super
far in the game
and i've had to stop for other games but
um
i don't know i i would
i could see you coming around on it i
think it would take a while though sure
take someone it would take someone to
like guide you through and like to more
sang too like those early dungeons are
boring as [ __ ] because it is just one
two three
one
three
so jean-luc we both know someone who's
very into final fantasy
who is always willing to accept new
people and train them in the ways of
final fantasy i can recommend that you
absolutely don't use him as your teacher
because surely that's not going to be
he'll like to fire it up and you'll be
like all right teach me how to be like
but man he'll be crying and [ __ ] and
he'll be like distracted
have you seen the episode of simpsons
where homer gets really fat on purpose
so you can like work from home all the
time yes yes and they install a computer
in his house and he's wearing his muumu
and he's got his little bird like eating
another thing and he's like and he sits
down at his computer and presses his
buttons with like one fat finger
that's how i feel when i play mmos and
i'm doing that i'm like
dude
dude pressing one button i'm like yeah
look at all these babies
um no i try and order a tab
uh yeah
and but i can i can get it that's i like
how uh
jean-luc went for an entire genre or an
entire mechanical
whole section of gaming i feel like i've
slowly come around on mmos over the
years but for a while like i just could
never get into any mmo i tried uh part
of it was the combat but part of it was
just like
i'm not the most i i like playing games
more by myself and like trying to play
an mmo without any sort of social
experience is like
[ __ ] pulling teeth with some of those
older mmos i feel like or they don't get
it right either way like one time me and
jake tried to play uh
elder scrolls online together because
i'm like okay it's got more active
combat like it's elder scrolls let's
play it together but then you try and do
the story stuff and you have to
individually listen to each person
talking so you can't be in a party when
you're trying to do the story and i'm
like is this an mmo or not like what do
you what do you want me to play by
myself or do you want me to play with
friends [ __ ] pick one
so
pick a [ __ ]
[ __ ] lane
the mmo that i played longest world
world of warcraft and let me tell you i
anytime someone spoke in that game i was
just like x don't care what you think
okay okay and then like i'm going to
i'll go into like uh like some
circle where people are talking about
the story of what a walker i like oh and
uh you see when illidan i was like
yeah yeah
absolutely yeah
yeah meanwhile i'm just like i've got a
hunter he's got a ball and he fires uh
good arrows uh sure
i could not tell you the story of world
of warcraft if you like put a gun to my
head yeah and i played many hours
game i think the mmo i've gotten the
furthest in was old republic because i
was just like it's star wars and i'm a
star wars person but even then i didn't
finish it because i was also like
yeah this is just like a less fun
version of kotor though like i'm just
like
just finish an mmo
well
but but they have a story mode right
like ideally you get to the max level
and you beat the story right and you get
like end credits i didn't even do that i
got stuck on alderaan at like level 30
because i was just grinding and i'm like
this is just this is this is boring i'm
done with this but
uh i can go next
and uh this is a game that i felt like i
was being gaslit by the entire world
because everyone was just like what a
what a game what a game and i was like
oh no am i am i going mad this is truly
awful i this is one of the worst video
game experiences i've ever played and
it's heavy rain
oh
yeah [ __ ] hell that game i swear to
god
everyone was losing it was every time i
turned to any anywhere it's like it was
winning an award and i was like
what's happening
i think what happens is it's like every
time a new quantic dream game comes out
there's a group of people that have
never played a quantic dream game like
discover it and feel that novelty
because it's like yeah i felt that way
when i played um
indigo prophecy for you know like a few
hours and then that game turns to [ __ ]
but like it feels very novel the first
time you play it and there's like a
there's like a indigo prophecy is
incredible it is the whole like the
whole in the restaurant cleaning the
diner where you have to clean up the
designer and then that i played that and
i was like this is one of the coolest
things i've ever yes then you go to the
next part of the game and it's like [ __ ]
it's absolute dog [ __ ] what happened and
then a mandatory uh
like flashback sequence where you have
to do mandatory stealth happens and
you're like [ __ ] this game this game is
there's a bit in that game i played on
pc where it's nothing but qtes but your
inner apartment the windows like fling
open and just a bunch of [ __ ] comes at
you from from the windows from outside
like [ __ ] like trash can and you've
got like dodge it and like the pc
controls were just so bad i was like i
can't believe it yeah like yeah heavy
rain i played it and i was like i
genuinely thought i was being ghastly by
the world i was like this is some of the
worst writing i have ever encountered
this story is awful these characters are
awful and like playing it is so dry and
then i was like i finished the game and
i was like
that was terrible and then the next day
is like
nominated for game of thrones
and it keeps happening
that game
that game is a nine out of ten when you
turn up the facial animations by 400 i
don't know
i've definitely seen that i mean yes
when you just spam the jason button for
like 10 minutes in the mall that game's
great
[Laughter]
for me like because every scene was
worse than the last every scene i felt
like was like every time they went to a
new scene it felt like i had started a
new movie in the middle and i was like
what's going on i don't understand
what's going on who are these characters
what is mystery what is happening it's
like everyone's terrible at this and
then like [ __ ] it won all these
awards and then
and look back at it and it's like
everyone now is like yeah maybe my game
wasn't so good and i was like thank you
can we retract all those awards and then
every like and then was it beyond two
cells came out yeah
i feel like people woke up at that point
beyond was after
was after detroit you know it was beyond
two souls then detroit yes
and when they announced beyond two souls
and like
uh quantic dream was obviously the
developer people got like it rejuvenated
people's love for heavy rain and people
were like oh remember heavy rain how
good that was and i was like don't do
this man don't do this yeah i think it's
like it was only when detroit came out
and everyone was like oh maybe these
were always bad and you're like yeah
funny thing is like i know a lot of
people that are like detroit is actually
their best one so i feel like i've i
have had like thoughts in my mind where
it's like maybe i should because i
didn't touch no no no here's the thing
go down don't go down this road
down this road those people are kind of
they're kind of right yeah detroit might
be the best one
it's still bad like i think i
yeah i think that like that the reason i
stayed away from it is because we did
that preview i can't remember what game
it was event it was but it was like me
and lucy sat next to each other in a
room full of other like journalists and
there was a demonstration of detroit
that's right is it right yeah detroit i
think it is where um the cara scene
where she's in a house yeah and she is
being like basically domestically
domestic violence oh they love
and and the person that was doing the
gameplay presentation was commentating
it as if it was an esport like genuinely
like [ __ ] ah
it was like too hyped for what was
happening
and it was like and here we have cara
running away and hiding under the bed
well the will oh no
and i was like
what's going on this is this is uh this
is a domestic violence scene do you know
what's going on and then we did an
interview after and i asked like some
questions that i think we've mentioned
this like i asked some very pointed
questions that got
got young david cage very heated and
then after that they were like we gotta
cancel all the interviews and i was like
i came out and like i came out and
started writing my interview because it
was just full and spicy and you just
didn't read it it's on game spot like it
was so spicy like i was like
like i asked them like really like
i asked the questions that needed to be
asked and then like went out typing it
up and then like i saw journalists
coming out of that room like looking
really upset
and and then i was like oh i wonder what
happened there maybe he's like got you
know popped up
or something happened and then there and
then i just heard in tons they cancelled
the interviews and i was like oh i think
that might have been my fault
but like since then i was like i'm not
touching this detroit game i don't want
anything to do with that i mean yeah
yeah yeah uh it was
it was yeah that that heavy rain i just
felt like
and then they were like hey we're
re-releasing it no no thank you i'm okay
um but you know it's uh
i am interested in seeing what they do
with star wars um i mean i'm not are you
are you
because i really am not mainly because
mainly because it seems like it's a
different crew of people
and and also like have you noticed how
david cage has not been mentioned once
in relation to star wars i wonder why
yeah
that studio has
jk gameplay for the upcoming harry
potter game they're like we just need to
distance ourselves from this one
individual as much as we can yeah i i do
wonder like because i i feel like
there's
there's no way they're letting him right
do that thing where he's like my script
is 7 000 pages and you're like
[ __ ] up
that means you read a bad script my dude
[Laughter]
but i feel like they've got i feel like
they were smart enough to bring in at
the very least i feel like disney is
like standing over them and being like
what are you typing where you go going
on that screen yeah that'd be good
well you just imagine mickey mouse with
like a baseball bat just like right
behind like what you're writing
yeah i feel like they got that on
lockdown and like
i'm interested to see what happens i
think this
i can't remember if it was a report that
came out where it was like that game was
just
something else entirely and then they
approached and then pitched it to disney
and disney was like star wars star wars
because they're like
so like i i'm interested to see what it
becomes um but yeah i i don't know man
heavy rain i just
a baffling game to me the day it was
released to now i even had that moment
you know why it upsets me because i i
had that moment where i let people
convince me it was good
and i was like
maybe maybe it is good and i just don't
really understand it that much and then
i and i and then i snapped out of it and
i was like maybe everyone else is wrong
you know what i remember about heavy
rain
the thinking of maybe everyone else is
wrong turned out to be the healthier
thought for me i i remember
renting heavy rain and playing it and my
friend came over and like his mom was
dropping him off and there's the scene
where um you're the detective guy and
he's like
i think he has to pull it like an
inhaler
and you have to like button mash to plug
inhaler and something about her seeing
me his mom see me like have to button
mash to use an inhaler
was like the funniest [ __ ] thing like
she was losing her shin she's like this
is the stupidest [ __ ] i have ever
[ __ ] seen what is this game
and i remember being like
she like shamed yeah she like
she like shamed me for playing it and i
was sitting there being like
you know what
she's right
this is really stupid
heavy rain deeply embarrassing to
moms uh yeah i just i i
i feel like oh the record needs to be
like revised on heavy rain i feel like
people need to go back and be like i
feel like history is on your side yeah i
feel like people now are like yeah this
game's not good and it turns out a lot
of their games aren't that good actually
generally i mean i'm sure they're people
like i think when detroit become human
came out and i don't remember what our
what our review was like at the time but
i do remember there was backlash from
people who were like what this is the
most incredible story i've ever seen in
a video game and it won an award from
someone yeah like it won like a best
narrative award and i was like
what the [ __ ]
baffling it's the the david cage award
for best scenario
[Music]
[Laughter]
he just like posted it from one hand to
the other
you win
[Laughter]
okay jordan what is your game
that you can't stand even though
everyone else loves it
it's minecraft like i thought about
like a spicier answer but i
i know that so many people love
minecraft minecraft is a great like
gateway drug of a game for lots of kids
to like get them into it because it's
pretty approachable and fairly
accessible yeah
uh but uh
despite the fact that i like playing
games like assassin's creed and valhalla
and odyssey and stuff like that i just
really don't like the games that meander
and just keep going on beyond like a
certain like threshold of time and i'm
like i've put so much time into
minecraft and it's still going and like
i know that's the point like there's no
end goal for minecraft like the end goal
is the satisfaction in being creative
and having a good time and i'm like but
where's my prize where's my
golden egg at the end of this rainbow
how to get those diamonds
are you not a lego kid
jordan
i know i was a huge lego kid i know you
said it but the irony of you saying that
you don't like games that meander and go
on for ages after saying that
assassin's creed games is just like
just well but i i understand it
completely
i i'm like half with you i think because
i really like the idea of minecraft and
there was a period where i play pretty
often with friends and i had a pretty
good time
and like whenever there's new updates
i'm like that sounds really cool and
then i load up the game and walk around
a little bit and i'm just like nah [ __ ]
this and then just
do it do i do i build another house like
a building yeah three houses each one
bigger than the last well
for me it's like i'm just gonna make the
same house i've built every time no
matter how hard i try to change it up
it's gonna look the same and i'm just
like all right that's that
peace
yeah
um
i don't get it i don't get the appeal
well no i do get the appeal it's just
not for me yeah i can't i can't do it
i've tried
i i played
i'd i've never played the actual main
game of minecraft i've only ever done
the creation mode which is incredible i
love that creation mode it's just flying
around and making stupid [ __ ] for ages
it's like a lot of fun but like i could
not tell you anything about that actual
like
the experience of playing the game the
only single player or like the only
campaign based on minecraft i've played
is minecraft dungeons which i bounced
off of like after about three hours we
did it on a stream with alana for like
um
play for all and that was it
um but yeah i feel like i would enjoy
minecraft more if i went on to pc and i
downloaded a lot of the
mods that people have made because like
there are like all those expansion stuff
like that where it's like oh you have to
collect all these materials it's going
to take you like 50 hours to do and by
the end you'll be able to build like a
spaceship and be able to go to the moon
where you'll find enough materials to
build a special type of spaceship where
you can go to mars and like kill this
alien monster and i'm like well that's
the goal that's a prize that i could
chase after and do and that could be fun
but i just
i don't know
i don't want to go through the hassle of
figuring out what mods i need and yeah
have you ever tried
playing it in like a server with like a
group of friends like that kind of
experience because that's kind of how
isla first played it uh like way back
when it came out with just like
i remember this was like early early
like alpha version um my friend was just
like hey i have this game called
minecraft we should all like buy it for
five bucks and i'll have a server and
like it was just kind of fun it's like
it's this thing you could just sort of
like hop into and just be like oh cool
that person built that and like
kind of almost in the way that i know my
my old roommate would like for about six
months straight he would just keep like
dropping like very obvious hints where
he's like you know i wouldn't mind just
like
going in on a minecraft server
like people wanted to play together i
just would not respond to him and i just
let those comments just like go by and
i'm like i i
don't wanna pay more money to play
something that i'm probably not going to
play very long because i would just jump
into the server and i would build
something and then i probably would just
never come back and i would not want to
like
i don't go to people's houses to see
what lego sets they've built i buy lego
so that i can fill in my own house with
cool lego sets and then i can look at
them whenever i want
that makes sense
i definitely think
i think like how i would have responded
to minecraft if i was like a kid when it
came out i probably would have been
obsessed with it you know or like a kid
now playing it like
i would have had so much fun i imagine
like i'd play that with my
that's probably what my friends and i
would spend most of our time doing
or maybe it's roblox i don't want to
think about that reality though
it's roblox and fortnight
yeah i guess uh
but but i i i see the appeal i
definitely see the appeal i think like
for me though i i
i enjoy like what minecraft has done for
the survival genre and i like seeing
like the forest is one of my favorite
games and that is heavily inspired by
minecraft whether i mean
supposedly allegedly heavily inspired by
minecraft because it is just building
survival but that does
that mixes horror there's a story to it
it keeps you on track like everything
you build has purpose it's not just like
i'm gonna build this because it looks
cool it's like i'm i have to build this
otherwise i'm gonna [ __ ] die
so like
that
i like the ideas that it brought to the
table but yeah i think minecraft itself
is like i just don't think we're the
audience for it
yeah that makes sense
any other honorable mentions for games
that you
just don't are not into despite the fact
that everyone else seems to be wildly i
mean i took a good name like fortnite or
almost every single call of duty over
the past like five six years or
year there's a bunch of games that are
just kind of like in the burglary
jake said something spicy under his
breath
i don't like it either jake so i'm here
with you
my mouth was like so confused
i've actually played a good amount of
that game i finished two of the endings
i think and i just didn't
to two of the major endings not like the
the joke endings um and it just didn't
do it for me i
could not get into that game no matter
how hard i try because you know people
are describing you know being in tears
playing it and i was like yeah i just
don't get it and people are always like
oh you just got to get this ending you
got to get that ending and i was like
i'm good i
i've i've given it a hell of a shot i
think i've got like 40 hours on steam in
that game or something so
nice
but not nice yeah um
yeah i i struggled with playing near
automata i love the character design i
love the story i love the music
especially i just did not enjoy playing
it
like the combat stuff was just not into
it either why were you where are you
grilling me for you
it doesn't lessen how spicy it is
someone has to take the bullet
okay you take the bullet and then i
stand in there and i'm like yeah i'll
take it i'll take it um
my experience of playing nier automata
was
starting up the game with my new ps4
getting to a point where you have to
like make a choice on like a certain
menu and the game like being paused like
in this menu and my mom uh at the time
being like hey jordan can you take out
the trash and me being a good son being
like yeah of course and leaving to take
out the trash and i did like a bunch of
other like things and i was gone for
maybe like 20 25 minutes and i come back
and the game's in like a completely
different spot because apparently it
moves on if you don't make a choice like
in that moment and i had no idea who
where i was who this character was who
was talking to me like this is stupid
this is dumb and i uninstalled it and
installed bloodborne and i
[Laughter]
speaking of games i hate bloodborne
wow just kidding wow wow wow wow
i
we
were
this episode has been strategically
like it's a strategic strike at michael
heinz hall
[Laughter]
you know what else
he listens to the podcast yeah michael i
am huge heavy rain fan you know what
i i i
completely want this is going to hurt a
lot of people i am 100
just completely ambivalent to undertale
like i just
kind of the same i was like well get it
i don't i don't really care for
undertale i love undertale but what's
what's the new one
yeah
like people lose their [ __ ] over that i
was like yeah seems fine
uh i guess it seems okay but everyone's
like flowey and
[ __ ]
song comes up i think the fan base
doesn't help it either no it really
doesn't
maybe like i'm because i played that
game i was like yep that was that's fine
uh but then the fan base comes out and
they had like similar heavy rain energy
we're like no this is the graveyard
i think it's just fine for me and
they're like no
did you not see
his name is sans and his text is written
in comic sans and i'm like
yep that's right
we should do one of now that this is
live
not this episode because i think we run
out of time but one episode we should
just have chat
say their favorite game and then we
roast them with that roast them
not them they're their faces gonna see
our numbers just slowly
one of our favorites oh i can't do mgs
three
oh throwing yakuza game
uh
yakuza games dude try okay here i'll
tell you the thing i actually they're
[ __ ] gross in the aksa games no i'll
tell you the thing i actually don't like
about i'd love the combat in the
occasion games but i'll tell you
anything i don't like is uh trying to
100
achievements in yakuza games is [ __ ]
impossible because you have to play
every goddamn mini game you have to like
master mahjong at like it it's it's oh
and it's like this [ __ ] [ __ ] rng
like dude
i cannot stand
trying to try and i've never done it
because it's just it's painful it's
awful did you say that you like the
combat in yakuza yeah i do like that yes
yeah i find it i i like it
i'm not gonna say it's like the greatest
combat ever but i do enjoy it
combat is
okay the yakuza games combat is designed
by someone who played streets of rage
once and they never played any other
game ever again
and
that is that is them start to finish
yeah like okay we played streets of rage
and now we're gonna do it and then yeah
stories are convoluted as [ __ ] their
stories make no sense whatsoever
meaningless [ __ ] where they just
create up one excuse after another to
get these
the okay characters to interface with
each other in a way that's supposed to
be dramatic every story if you think
about it is the same okay they're all
the same story it's kiryu and majima
doing the same [ __ ] every uh they do it
all end on millennium tower the stories
are all they say they have the same
energy as fast and furious they're all
just being family this family
and it's like [ __ ] hell come up with
a actual storyline instead of oh no i
got kicked out of the yakuza again i
better look after this child or this cat
oh no i need to figure out this mystery
better go race rc cars for 30 hours
um that is just imagining someone
pulling up
yeah just
saying
as fast in the people
because i adore the youngers
we have to roast it i [ __ ] love the
yakuza game so
um i've got i've like i've got the
original yakuza games as well like i
love those games to death but yeah
yeah we can do a roast in the future
yeah
um even if it does hurt us
i see someone saying witcher 3 and i'm
like oh okay i would do it do it jake
someone said roasted someone said
someone said
i was like oh i don't know i'm ready for
that now
i can't do it
i need
yeah
so hopefully no one clips that out of
context and just like this guy hates
yakuza games i
really hope that we get like a clip of
damn badmouthing yakuza
[Laughter]
anyways
thank you for watching another or
listening to another episode of the
gamespot after dark podcast
um hopefully next time
we'll be back in the um the studio
uh the office studio all in person we
just like we said at the top of the show
we had a couple things come up where it
was like some people not feeling great
some people have deadlines immediately
and some people just can't be asked
because they live in l.a for some reason
[ __ ] insane [ __ ] going on why are you
living up there come back to san
francisco um
and uh yeah so hopefully in the in the
next one will be uh we'll be all in live
and in person again a few of us anyway
um uh if you don't already subscribe to
the podcast rate it review it on
whatever your podcast services if you're
watching it live
make sure you follow the twitch channel
and share it with some friends just tell
your friends be like hey there's a lot
of podcasts it's pretty funny they roast
their favorite games for no reason
whatsoever
yeah they talk [ __ ] about david cage for
like a solid 30
minutes and uh yeah and hopefully we'll
see you in the next one
all right everyone good bye
wait
what have you stopped i i just no i just
want to give a shout out to um
uh in the gamespot discord uh if you're
not in it you should join but uh
um
oh god i was thinking about this for a
while uh that we we have like a game
pass game club thing that that one of
the mods started that's really cool
where they they vote for a game pass
game and then people play it and
talk about it so if that sounds cool
dude i think the game right now is
stable um so if that's up your aisle if
you haven't played stable and you want
to do that make sure to uh join in and
join the discord and such sorry i just
wanted to make sure that you got across
i didn't even see that pop up so i
missed that but i'm very very into that
yeah um jump in and and uh play some
games with us
and we will see you again anyone else
got anything else they want to interrupt
me with
yes no yeah
okay good
um see you next time everyone bye
[Music]
[Music]
you